ja meine damen und herren hotel wir
reden jetzt hier im studio weiter jörg
butt ist bei mir oberste ade bei der
luftwaffe wahnsinnig wurde auch
krisenmanager und sie kennen noch die
krim weil sie selber darüber geflogen
sind wie ist ihre einschätzung ich sage
es einmal so global von die situation
jetzt heute an diesen mut haben nach wie
vor am fünften tag total verwundert dass
russland noch nicht in kiew ist also
irgendetwas läuft der komplett falsch
entweder sind es wirklich die
logistischen probleme
verbunden mit der ungeheuren kampfkraft
der ukraine oder aber es ist
beabsichtigt dass putin eben den ganz
großen schlag noch nicht will und beides
ist möglich der ganz große schlag wäre
dass er mit raketenangriffen und das
militär ist da steht bereit das land
über rollen könnte und das hat er bisher
nicht gemacht er hat offen gestanden
noch nicht mal einer als die stadt
richtig eingenommen die von ukrainischen
soldaten beschützt wird nein er kommt
einfach nicht voran aber wir sollten
vorsichtig sein möglicherweise ist das
wie gesagt gewollt und wir müssen
abwarten was jetzt bei den verhandlungen
rausgekommen ist ich denke das liegt
auch sehr stark an die lenski wie weit
er zu bestellen ist und wieso könnt ihr
das denn gewollt sein helfen sie uns das
zu verstehen weil ein großer schlag in
dem man also sehr schnell dann auch
tatsächlich kiew einnimmt und damit
vielleicht die regierung austauschen
kann das hätte ja viele vorteile der an
staatsminister stück das ist ja auch
viele vorteile und man muss sehen er hat
trotz vieler soldaten einfach nicht
genug um die ukraine zu halten also
reinmarschieren ist eine geschichte aber
wie will er dieses relativ großer land
dann halten also lautet er im augenblick
vielleicht aus ob es andere
möglichkeiten gibt wir sollten auch
nicht vergessen und umkirch 30 kilometer
im umkreis stehen die russen die kräfte
die könnten jederzeit los ich denke die
haben den befehl noch nicht dazu und in
der stadt sollen auch killerkommandos
unterwegs sein die eben nach dem leben
des präsidenten und der regierung
trachten also das ist ein großer brand
punkt und es kann sein dass morgen und
übermorgen schon wieder alles anders ist
also sie sehen das so zu sagen sie
sollen verheerende situation jetzt am
wochenende und heute tatsächlich der
vollzug die die atomaren waffen in eine
zweite stufe zwei von vier stufen einer
alarmbereitschaft zu versetzen wie
bewerten sie das das würde ich das ist
eine ernste geschichte aber es ist
druckpotenzial geht an sich nicht in
richtung ukraine sondern mehr in
richtung nato hallo wir sind bereit
passt schön auf wir haben noch mehr
möglichkeiten
im augenblick wirklich überbewerten also
dort dort eher ruhig bleibt absolut die
entscheidung deutschlands jetzt
tatsächlich eine 180 grad wendung in der
in der politik durchzuführen aber auch
die eu nämlich kriegswaffen in dieses
also waffen in dieses kriegsgebiet
tödliche waffen zu liefern sie sehen
mich im augenblick grad sogar ein
bisschen lächeln ich warte eigentlich
seit 30 jahren darauf dass wir unseren
verpflichtungen der nato nach einkommen
sagen das ist richtig natürlich ist es
richtig und es wurde allerhöchste zeit
und wenn es jetzt gemacht wird dann
frage ich mich tatsächlich warum wurde
es sich schon schuljahr gemacht denn
jetzt haben wir die situation dass die
waffen erstmal in das land rein kommen
müssen und es kann sein dass morgen oder
übermorgen die grenzen schon gesperrt
sind und die waffen dann
schlimmstenfalls entweder sind sie
trennen die leute sind noch nicht
ausgebildet oder aber die russen
übernehmen die waffen also recht knapp
das heißt es schnell gehen dann auch
schon eher ein symbolischer schritt so
ein bisschen ja ja ja also wir sind
einfach in der situation dass nach wie
vor david gegen goliath kämpft und
selbst wenn diese genannten waffen
reinkommen das verhältnis zwischen den
streitkräften hat sich nicht wesentlich
ändern
trotzdem sie sagen ist es richtig und
sie sind zufrieden stellen sich dahinter
trotzdem in die frage muss gestattet
sein
heizmann damit ein konflikt nicht weiter
an unnötig an in dem jetzt eben
tatsächlich noch mehr patronen raketen
hineingepasst die große gefahr ich habe
bis vor ein paar tagen auch davor
gewarnt eben diese kräfte dort rein zu
bringen weil
putin gereizt werden könnte aber wir
leben in einer welt die sich jeden tag
dynamisch dreht wir dürfen nicht
vergessen welche enorme unterstützung
der westen politisch wirtschaftlich in
dieser sache rein bringt und das hat
tatsächlich auch die strategische lage
verändert aber wir sollten das nicht
überreizen die geschichte wird uns in
wenigen tagen zeigen ob es richtig oder
falsch waren
ich hätte ja eben schon gesagt sie
kennen die krim von oben sowieso sorgen
aus der perspektive eines eines
luftwaffen piloten eines fliegers die
forderung die putin aufgestellt hat und
jetzt auch wieder aufgestellt hat auf
gar keinen fall also gibt in die krim
zurück an die ukraine wie bewerten sie
das völlig illusorisch also die krim
wird natürlich völkerrechtlich nicht
anerkannt und ich kann mir auch nicht
vorstellen dass die ukraine mit einem
zugeständnis des präsidenten sozusagen
finanziert wird das geht nicht mehr es
muss ein wunder passieren denn die
verhandlung die jetzt laufen und man
höre den otto und der von micron kommt
wie die forderung waren die der die
putin genannt hat dass die sache zu
einem erfolg wird ich glaube was ganz
anderes die lösung liegt überhaupt nicht
in der ukraine die lösung liegt
tatsächlich im umfeld von putin wissen
wir was im augenblick der verteidigungs
minister oder der generalstabschef
wirklich denken ich habe gestern die
gesichter beobachtet als putin eben
seine befehle herausgebracht hat da war
ein kurzes zucken zu sehen warten wir
doch erst mal ab wie stark putin in den
nächsten tagen wirklich bleibt also sie
denken man muss gucken ob wenig rückhalt
verliert in der in reiner allen ängsten
rein das würde ja auch dazu passende aus
der korrespondent der mir von osten eben
gesagt hat dass die oligarchen sich
jetzt auch ja die union zum teil die
oligarchen sind vielleicht nicht so
stark also putin könnte auch mit weniger
die gleichen nur das geld die haben
punktuell das geld aber in wirklichkeit
es ist wirklich der gesamte sanktions
apparat und der dort putin und und
russland kurzfristig zum leiten bringen
das ist der druck